santiago incluso en estados donde ganó
donald trump en estados republicanos los
cascos urbanos terminaron votando por yo
bailé él fue el caso de miami en la
florida de charlotte en carolina del
norte incluso de dallas y houston en
texas les quiero compartir datos
precisos que publica en new york times
sobre la preferencia de los demócratas
en los cascos urbanos en ciudades
superiores a 50.000 personas el 37 por
ciento de los votantes votó por trump el
60 por ciento lo hizo por bailén en
suburbios el 48 por ciento votó por
trump y el 51 por bailén y en las áreas
rurales precisamente el 54 por ciento de
los votantes votó por donald trump
mientras que el 45 lo hizo por joe biden
ahora presidente electo en cuanto a las
mujeres le quiero pues volver a
mencionar unos datos que creo que son
importantes las mujeres el 49 por ciento
de ellas de ellas voto por donald trump
perdón el 43 otro por donald trump el 56
voto por joe biden en cuanto
el 49 voto por donald trump y el 48 por
job alien entre los afroamericanos el
12% por trump el restante por joe biden
y en cuanto a los latinos que nos
interesa a nosotros el 32% terminó
votando por donald trump mientras que el
66 por el presidente electo joe biden
que este vale un tema que a partir de
ahora interesa muchísimo es el gabinete
de bailén qué información maneja al
respecto
es importante porque pues en esas
alianzas que empezó a ser yo vaivén para
poder llegar a la presidencia estuvo la
alianza que hizo con el ala progresista
del partido demócrata es decir la el ala
que representa bronis andrés y alexandra
ocasio corte es la congresista y eso
pues va a influir obviamente en los
puestos en el gabinete que va a terminar
dando joe biden por ejemplo ya se
empieza a considerar varios nombres en
york times' maneja una lista de 500
nombres entre ellos obviamente
progresistas por ejemplo bernie sanders
podría ir como lo reporta el medio de
nueva york a ser el secretario de
trabajo joaquín castro ex alcalde de san
antonio en texas podría ser nuevamente
el secretario de urbanismo y el
elizabeth warren senadora por
massachusetts podría terminar siendo la
próxima secretaria del tesoro de eeuu
para criticar a una pregunta que surge
teniendo en cuenta en este escenario
político y sobre todo también social que
se vive en eeuu es cómo podrías joe
biden acercarse de alguna manera y
romper quizás la distancia
con los seguidores de donald trump con
los más acérrimos por ejemplo que siguen
denunciando fraude electoral
claro además y vinculándolo y
articulando con el tema que le estaba
mencionando va a ser difícil porque los
republicanos pues van a estar en el
congreso y pues si obtienen la mayoría
va a ser difícil aprobar precisamente
estos nombres que va a proponer yo byron
como presidente para su gabinete pero
los cuatro puntos que podrían
precisamente vincular acercar más esta
división curar esa división entre azules
y rojos demócratas y republicanos sería
primero pues precisamente quien quien
quien nombra en el gabinete segundo pues
un cambio visible en la economía general
bastante empleo invertir en
infraestructura y por último para darle
muchas bolas al tema de la cobertura en
salud eso afectará a todos los
americanos independientemente del
partido